Lucas on va prendre la direction du
loircher à présent où les élus
écologistes ont décidé de chausser les
bottes la France a perdu 100000
agriculteurs et agricultrices entre 2010
et 2020 c'est à partir de ce constat que
les élus ont choisi d'aller à la
rencontre du monde paysan leur objectif
accompagner la transition du modèle
agricole pour nourrir l'humain tout en
protégeant le vivant les écologistes
expliquent par ailleurs que 50 % des
agriculteurs et agricultrices seront en
âge de partir à la retraite dans les 10
prochaines années mais que seul une
ferme sur trois trouve Act actuellement
un repreneur hier avant-hier pardon des
échanges ont eu lieu dans le Loir etcher
en amont de l'étude de la loi
d'orientation et d'avenir agricole hélè
chapelet était sur place en région
Centre seulement 4,9 % des surfaces
cultivées le sont en bio on est donc
très loin des 25 % voulus par l'Union
européenne d'ici 2030 dans ce champ de
cols a aucun pesticide quand il a repris
l'exploitation de son père il y a 15 ans
David a décidé de passer au bio une
démarche qui n'est pas que pers
personnel aider ou maintenir de la bio
sur son territoire est bon pour tout le
monde pour pour le citoyen mais
également pour les coûts de coût de la
société en généraux en général sur sur
la santé sur le traitement de l'eau par
exemple sur les pollutions de l'air sur
la biodiversité et également sur
l'emploi si on prend l'exemple de ma
ferme j'étais en conventionnel quand je
me suis installé j'étais seul sur
l'exploitation aujourd'hui on est quatre
sur la ferme notamment grâce à cette
conversion en bio cet été ce cols sera
transformé en huile est vendu en circuit
court sur des marchés ou via des
magasins bio c'est ce que David explique
d'ailleurs à ses visiteurs du jour des
élus écologistes comme l'eurodéputé
Claude gruffa ou le député d'indrloir
Charles Fournier eux sont venus redire
leur attachement à ce type d'agriculture
aujourd'hui touché par l'inflation le
dérèglement climatique et le manque de
soutien de la part des institutions ça
fait 80 ans qu'on qu'on aide
l'agriculture
polluante et les lobbyes ont une telle
puiss aujourd'hui que rien ne change on
a dépassé toutes les limites dans plein
de domaines que soit l'environnement que
ce soit la santé des humains et des
paysans on est dans une situation il
faut il faut absolument que les change
ch ben non c'est économie d'abord et on
change rien au système alors que l'on
sait qu'un virage est nécessaire pour la
planète et ses ressources il y a un mois
le Parlement européen a rejeté l'idée de
réduire de moitié l'utilisation des
pesticides d'ici 2030 un jour noir pour
les écologistes une victoire salué par
la FNSEA qui trouvait le délai
intenable